comme l'enseignement catholique est
menacée dans son existence et que c'est
la liberté d'enseignement qui est ainsi
menacée nous sommes un certain nombre de
parlementaires 330 exactement députés et
sénateurs qui voulant empêcher cela
alors nous allons déposer une soumission
de loi qui permettra la pose de verrou
contre une nationalisation dont nous
voulons à aucun prix parce que nous
voulons ni du journal unique ni du parti
unique ni de l'école unique et cette
proposition de loi donnera à
l'enseignement kass'moustik à
l'enseignement privé des conditions de
vie qui lui permettront d'exister à côté
de l'enseignement public contre lequel
nous devons bien entendu aucune
hostilité
donc vous êtes contre la formule la
gauche qui dit affronte publics écoles
publiques et privées affront privé ceci
est une imposture tout à fait est une
imposture grave parce que ça prétendrait
que ce les parents qui mettent leurs
enfants dans l'enseignement privé ne
paie pas d'impôts comme les autres ce
qui est tout à fait faux naturellement
et en plus il est tout à fait clair que
dès lors que les écoles privées ne
serait plus aidées par l'état il
faudrait que chaque famille pour chaque
enfant dépenses à peu près 300 mille
francs par an ce qui est hors de la
portée de la plupart des familles
françaises et qui réserve vrai donc le
droit à la liberté aux seules personnes
et aux seules familles qui pourrait
payer
c'est insupportable dans une démocratie